if you follow the tech world you're
probably familiar with the Chinese giant
tensent tensent is the largest Chinese
tech company with a market cap of $376
billion and they have their arms in
everything from gaming and social media
to payments and investing but likely
their most notable product is their
super app WeChat WeChat is basically
ubiquitous with a total of 827 million
users within just China and this
ubiquity isn't surprising given that we
chat attempts to do everything you can
buy groceries book planes and hotels
make payments message people read the
news get food delivery have a video call
play video games and basically whatever
else you want for years American
companies have looked at WeChat with
pure Envy as they too want a super app
that encompasses every aspect of
people's lives and it seems that the
latest tech billionaire to jump onto
this bandwagon is Elon Musk who wants to
turn X into an everything app he says
that for X to succeed the platform needs
to compete with YouTube LinkedIn
FaceTime dating apps and for some reason
the entire banking industry given that
Elon basically has infinite resources
actually developing such an app and
putting it in front of people would not
be too difficult but actually getting
people to use it well that's a whole
another story Google Facebook and apple
have been trying to do this for over a
decade now slowly expanding to one
industry after another but to this day
they're all very much depend dependent
on their hero product 58% of all of
Google's revenue still comes from search
ads 52% of Apple's revenue is still
comes from the iPhone and 96% of meta's
Revenue still comes from just Facebook
and Instagram and that's despite these
companies expanding to dozens and dozens
of sectors and industries often betting
as much as a hundred billion doar
clearly infinite money and resources
have not allowed any of these guys to
create a true super app so here's why a
super app has has never worked in
America and YX won't be any
different likely the biggest Factor
preventing a super app from blowing up
in America is public hesitance the
majority of the public already feels
that big Tech has too much power and
they feel no need to start using even
more offerings from any one of these
companies and whenever a big tech
company tries to push such a vision
people not only tend to not buy in but
often resist likely the best example of
this was with Google+ if you're not
familiar with go+ it was basically
Google's attempt to take on Facebook and
create their own social media platform
they were relatively early too as they
would launch a network in mid 2011 on
paper Google+ actually started off
pretty strong within 2 weeks of launch
they got 10 million users within a month
they had 25 million users and within 2
years they had over half a billion users
surely this was a massive success right
well that is until you peel back the
layers you see while Google was able to
get a bunch of users on board these
weren't exactly excited or loyal users
for example Google made it nearly
impossible to open a Gmail account
without creating a Google+ profile they
also locked a bunch of useful
functionality behind Google+ if you
wanted to see reviews from your friends
you needed Google+ if you wanted to see
the leaderboards on the Play Store you
needed Google+ if you wanted to use
Google Hangout you needed Google+ likely
the worst infraction though was when
Google required users to have a Google+
account to leave comments on YouTube
this move generated so much backlash
that one of YouTube's Founders jward Kem
came out of his eight-year Slumber to
say why the F do I need a Google+
account to comment on a video all of
this backlash would lead to Google
rolling back many of these policies but
it's not like things would have played
out any differently even if they hadn't
rolled these back the reality was that
while they were able to get over half a
billion accounts 90% of user sessions
lasted less than 5 seconds and Google
would eventually end up shutting down
the platform in 2019 now you might be
inclined to say that this failure was
largely just because Google did not
understand the social media space but
honestly I don't think that would have
made much of a difference which brings
us into our next example threat I think
we can all agree that meta is the
Undisputed king of social media with
multiple platforms with billions of
users each so you would think that they
would have a great shot at taking down
Twitter especially given the poor Optics
after elon's takeover and to threads
credit they did have an insane launch
reaching 100 million users within just 5
days but this was followed by an
explosive fall as well as threads would
lose 80% of its daily active users
within just 1 month and Google Plus and
threads are just two notable examples
there's plenty of examples just like
this across Tech the Microsoft soft Zoom
the Windows Phone Bing Edge the Google
pixel Google meets Google Classroom Bing
Maps Google B and on and on and on it
seems that these Tech leaders think that
people will be super ecstatic about
having yet another big Tech account or
service they expect people to be like oh
wow I can do Twitter on threads now this
is a game changer I can't wait to ditch
Twitter in reality people are more like
oh cool meta has a new app now I'll
check it out none of this is to say that
these companies can't launch successful
product in an adjacent or even
completely different industry but the
bottom line is that these company
resources and ubiquity doesn't exactly
make it any more likely that these new
products will succeed especially on the
scale that you would expect them to
succeed and that's largely because it's
only these companies and their leaders
who are actually jumping up and down
about the idea of a super
app sometimes big Tech is able to
overcome the odds and launch a new
successful widely used product in a
completely different industry but
they're not home free yet because now
they have to make the Venture actually
worthwhile which is an even bigger
challenge likely the best example of
this is Apple's fora into the financial
industry in early 2019 Apple announced
that they were going to launch a credit
card a credit card that easily
integrated into the Apple ecosystem came
with a beautiful UI and encouraged
strong financial habits from the very
beginning credit card enthusi s weren't
a big fan of the card while they didn't
have anything particularly bad to say
about the card They simply felt that
there were better options on the market
in terms of rewards and benefits but
despite their concerns the Apple card
would go on to be a massive success
amongst the general public growing to
over 6 million card holders it turns out
that the average person far preferred
the Simplicity and convenience of the
Apple card over maximizing credit card
points with MX or chase and that's still
the case to this day the general public
still really likes the Apple card the
same however cannot be said about
Goldman Sachs the issuer of the Apple
card who has lost over a billion dollars
largely due to Apple's lack of
understanding of the credit card Market
you see apple largely approached the
Apple card with the tech mindset and
that's largely why it was so well
received but this was also the card's
biggest Pitfall for example with tech
you want your products to be as widely
accessible as possible that's why Apple
kept the credit requirements for the
Apple card super low they wanted it to
be as easily accessible as possible and
to make it easy for first-time credit
card holders to build their credit but
while that's a great sentiment it also
led to a quarter of their credit card
loans going out to people with credit
scores below 660 leading to the worst
bank loss rate of any big us card issuer
but not only is the Apple card losing
money on its subprime customers they're
also not making any money on their good
standing customers thanks to the Apple
card's great UI and insistence that you
pay off your credit card bills making
money on good standing customers is
nearly impossible this isn't to say that
Apple has to be predatory in order to
make money many MX cards for example
don't even allow customers to carry
balances but MX is still able to make a
bunch of money from these customers
because they charge annual membership
fees and have other modes of
monetization Apple however is stuck in a
very tricky situation their subprime
customers are defaulting left and right
credit card enthusiasts don't want
anything to do with the Apple card and
their average customers always pay their
entire balance and never pay any
interest yeah I don't think you'd be
surprised to hear that Apple has agreed
to end their credit card and savings
accounts Partnerships with Gman sax but
honestly I don't think Apple could have
really avoided this fate the reality is
that it takes time to truly understand
and compete in an industry such as
credit cards immediately launching to
six million card holders much of whom
have never had a credit card before is
bound to cause issues which brings me
into the fundamental difference between
China and
America I don't want to get too
political here but the reality is that
launching a product in America and China
are very different for a product to
truly be successful in China you very
much need the blessing of the CCP which
companies like tensent already have
that's why they're able to expand into
any industry or sector with ease they're
often the biggest player in that
industry or they're even the first
player in that industry this makes
capturing market share a Walkin the park
but it's completely different in America
when an American company tries to create
a super app and expand to different
Industries they're competing with highly
established and competitive players and
Brands Apple for example was taking on
American Express Chase City capital 1
and all of the other big Banks but we
don't even have to look at a different
industry as this is true within the tech
industry itself with goog Plus Google
was competing against met
with Bing and Edge Microsoft was
competing against Google and with the
Windows Phone Microsoft was competing
against Apple and Google and there's so
many examples just like this any
industry that these guys want to expand
to is already dominated by one of their
biggest Rivals and unless these guys let
up or drop the ball for some reason
expanding cure is nearly impossible so
ironically one of the biggest factors
preventing a tension style Monopoly is
the big Tech oligopoly none of them are
going to let the other eat their lunch
but even putting that aside Americans
simply aren't interested in a super app
in fact they actually like having
separation take the financial industry
for example you can have basically any
one of your financial needs be taken
care of by Chase or Wells Fargo or any
one of these big Banks but the average
American doesn't just have one Chase
account or one Wells Fargo account they
actually have 25 to 40 Financial
accounts they have a few checking
accounts a few savings accounts one or
two HSA accounts a couple of credit
cards a couple of payment platforms a
couple of investing and trading
platforms a few loan providers and a few
financial management software providers
the reason being that one they like
separation and two each account is good
at something specific whether that be
investing or credit cards and mobile
payments or whatever and it's the same
thing with tech people have their
favorite social media apps their
messaging apps their streaming services
their games their browsers their emails
their operating systems and so on
Americans tend to choose the offering
they like the most from each sector to
create an assortment of tech services
that let them enjoy the best of all
worlds like a true free market and until
that changes and Americans want a
product just because it's from Ax or
meta or Google or whatever big Tech
really has no chance of creating a true
super app with historically High
interest rates the appeal of bills and
bonds is higher than ever yet
traditional brokerages haven't really
adapted with the times they still expect
people to use clunky Bond tables scroll
through long overwhelming lists and even
use Virtual keyboards till recently and
that's why we created our own modern
Bond platform Silo at Silo we prioritize
the user experience and the ease of
finding and investing in the issuers you
know and trust so that you too can
easily lock in high yields also choosing
a strong user experience does not mean
sacrificing unsafety every Salo account
is ensured by 500,000 in sipc insurance
and $2.5 million in FDIC Insurance also
all funds deposited on the platform will
be maintained by our trusted custodian
interactive brokers who has experienced
managing $373 billion worth of assets
over the past 45 years so if you're
looking for a modern way to invest in
bonds please consider checking out Silo
in the description below would you want
to super app comment that down below
also surprisingly it looks like OG
Facebook is the closest to creating such
as super app at least within the social
media space check out this video to
learn more but until then I'm Hari and
I'll see you guys on the next
one